Est-ce qu'on a besoin de se
défendre?
- Le lancement est réussi,
et son objectif est clair :
s'écras'écras'écras'écraser suï,
qui se trouve à 11 millions
de kilomètres de la Terl'impacta
le faire dévier de sa course.C's
la mise en place d'un système
de défense planéollision
entre la comète Shoemaker-Levy
et Jupiter, en 1994, qui a
ouvert les yeux des astronomes
sur l'importanceès des astéroïds
qui circulent en périphérie
de la Terre.
Depuis 20 ans, on en a détecté
tailles qu'on suit maintenant
artir du sol.
ANDRÉ GRANDCHAMPS, astronome,
Planétarium Rio - Depuis ce tema
plusieurs projets qui ont
lancés pour essayer de
répertorier les astéroïdes.
pour essayer de se protéger
de ça, mais on a jamais rien
testé grandeur nature.
relativement simple. D'un côté,
un boulet de 750
se déplace à 24 000 km/heure;
de l'autre, sa cible :
Dymorphos, une minuscule léroïï.
En septembre 2022, le boulet va
percuter sa cible dans l'espoir
de modifier très légèrement
Un micro satellite de la NASA,
des télescopes terrestres et,
en 2024, une sonde européenne
vont ensuite mesurer précisément
l'effet de cette collision vitee
de Dymorphos.
- Le choix de l'astéroïde
n'est pas anodin. Si on ava suïe
tout seul, ça aurait été t
difficile de voir les impacts
à long terme, ça auraitzaines d.
- Les experts sa
modification même extrêmement
faible de la trad'un ad'un ad'ï,
sur de très stances,
influer énormément
sa destination fAssez, espèrent,
pour éviter dans
une hypothétique collision entre
un gro
Un événement improbable
à m, mais, mais, mais, mais, mas
théoriquement possible.
- Le r
effectivement. Mais il pourrait
ts qu'on n'a pas
trouvés encore, on s'en doute,
qu'il y a un risque, bien,
va être
de le découvrir le plus tôt
des stratégies efficaces
e défendre contre ça.
- On évalue qu'il y a plus
qui circulent dans lesdeux pdeus
du système solaire.
de diamètre et selon l'endroitùt
causer d'énormes dommages.
Radio-Canada, M